what is frustrating is she can say
things like republicans want to defund
the police she can say things like no
americans are stranded in afghanistan
she can say these verifiably false
things which no press secretary should
be able to say because they're just
simply not truthful and then you compare
that and they just let her get away with
it very few fact checks compare that to
like when i said the science uh should
not get in the way of opening schools
because the science is on our side jim
acosta can take the first half the
science should not get in the way uh
make it go viral on twitter msnbc it
will be on every chiron when it's the
direct opposite of what i was saying but
they just removed the context
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former white house press secretary
co-host of outnumbered on fox news and
author of the brand new book for such a
time as this my faith journey through
the white house and beyond kaylee
mcinanny finally welcome to the reuben
report
thank you it's about time thanks for
having me we are long long overdue for
this conversation i've wanted to talk to
you since you were press secretary but i
reference you on the show one way or
another several times a week because i
often play clips of jen saki and then i
juxtapose her with you
but before we get to that because i'm
sure we'll have plenty of plenty of that
type of stuff can you tell me a little
bit about your bio which is partly what
the book is about
just what kind of led you to becoming
somebody that became press secretary and
then we'll get to the last couple years
yeah well like many young conservatives
across the country i grew up listening
to the great uh rush limbaugh my dad's
pickup truck um i used to live in plant
city florida i'd drive to tampa where i
went to school and so um i was really uh
just got this passion within me
listening to rush i love politics from a
young age going back to when i was eight
years old it just was um a burning
desire and you know i worked um through
media through politics started out at
fox news as a producer
left got involved with trump world and
the rnc and the trump campaign and then
the trump white house and it just was
kind of a step-by-step ladder
progression and one that i believe
and the title you see for such a time as
this that god wanted me there in that
moment for such a time as this um in
that time during covet 19 as press
secretary so you were a conservative
basically from eight years old and on
oh yes born and raised a conservative it
always made a lot more sense to me than
the other side
i've come to agree with you um all right
so let's talk a little bit about the the
press secretary portion of this because
i find the press secretary
the job itself to me is like one of the
most fascinating jobs on earth that in
essence you have an administration that
has talking points you have reporters
that are supposed to be asking you
contrarian questions but in your case it
was like
it wasn't just contrarian questions it
was trying to basically destroy you guys
every day
what were what were some of your kind of
guiding principles as you would you know
go into that room every day
so when i first thought about taking the
job you know i came in and i thought i'm
going to give the press a chance i know
who i'm up against this is the liberal
media i know they're going to be unfair
i've watched what they've done to trump
for three plus years um but i said let's
give it a chance and i said i'll have a
red line should they cross that red line
of going personal with me um i'll be
prepared to fight back do so politely
and gently and gracefully but i will
fight back and i won't be pummeled and
run over so my dad said to me come up
with a motto for your office and i said
offense only that's our motto we're
going to be on offense we're not going
to be the republican that lays down and
takes it we're not going to be the
administration that uh you know loses an
argument we're going to be the
administration that brings the truth to
the american people but brings what i
think is uh what is needed most with
this press corps accountability with a
capital a uh we'll read their headlines
to them because i believe in
accountability so we'll fight back
offense only that was our motto it's the
whole title of a chapter in my book so
you did just that i mean you would read
headlines back to them you would call
them out on stories that they butchered
or ignored you'd show video clips i mean
nobody really i don't think did that
before you and saki certainly doesn't do
it since show video clips exposing the
nonsense that they were putting forth
did you feel like you were getting
through to them or that they just i mean
as most of my audience i think believes
at this point they just have their
agenda they were there to destroy you
and they're basically there to now
protect the administration
yeah i think i did get through to them i
think i remember as my second briefing
it was the first time
that i kind of read headlines back to
them because i told you that red line
was crossed
jeff mason asked a very personal
question um a out of context video clip
that um based on a remark that i made
before covid hit back when fauci was out
there saying oh cloven has a meninsual
threat to our country i was echoing that
same line and uh they took that and
asked me about it in briefing number two
and you know i had conveniently just
read all of their misinformation on
covet literally right before going to
the podium so i had that tabbed and
ready to go and uh jeff mason who's
actually a nice person so i feel bad
that he was the one that the headline uh
reading happened to um but you know i
could see the audible shock on their
faces um because i was told coming into
the job half of your job is to work for
the press half of it's to work for the
president but when the press has stopped
working for the people who i'm
ultimately working for um my job's not
have to work for the press anymore my
job's to work for the american people
and to me that meant reading the
headlines i do think it broke through to
them at least a little
what was the stress like just like
personally i mean it's not the pro it's
probably not the most fun job on earth
i'm sure you get some kicks out of it
and there's some fun moments but like
you know you were basically enemy number
one for these people because you were
you know sort of guarding trump in
essence
yeah i mean there were definitely
stressful days like one that comes to
mind is uh i was literally about to go
to the podium i think it was one o'clock
and the woodward book dropped that the
audio recordings on cnn so you can
imagine i prepared a whole briefing on
whatever else the news of the day was
and
moments before my briefing it's almost
as if cnn had planned it uh the drop and
so very little time to prepare i didn't
have time to call people across the
administration just had to do the best i
could so days like that are stressful
but i will say we had a lot of fun and i
think that's why i believe my press shop
excelled is because we had fun with the
press we love brainstorming all the
ridiculous things they could ask us and
oftentimes we would find the absolute
hardest question to answer we'd identify
it but because most of them don't do
their homework usually the hardest
question was never asked so i've heard
you answered this question before but
can you talk a little bit about what
trump's relationship with you was like
because you were basically the filter to
the press if he wasn't just jumping on
twitter
yeah so he was very
appreciative of me i think he loved the
way i held the press accountable and
liked my style um so i mean i remember
reading about his relationship with
members of the administration before i
came in and what a hard boss he is and
he's menacing and angry and all these
things that you know the press said
about him and look certainly he expected
a lot from you and i would hope a
president expects a lot from any staff
um but he was fun to work around he he
appreciated what i did he would always
compliment me um so it was kind of like
a
father-daughter situation and that um i
could tell he really cared about me as a
person um still does and you know i
loved him he was a great boss so when
you compare your experience to then what
you're covering on outnumbered every day
and some of the other stuff that you're
doing on fox with what goes on with saki
i mean i play clips of her every week it
is so clear to me
that she doesn't believe what she's
saying she can't in my line as always if
you asked her what her favorite color
was she would say four she cannot say
something true she said and you can read
it on her face
what do you make of the job she's doing
the way the press is treating her if it
wasn't for peter ducey i mean nobody
would be giving her a confrontational
question
yeah that's right i mean comparison you
know she was asked about the white house
cat the white house dog being involved
in fighting it incident the airport fun
color scheme i mean i was asked about
the drapes the drapes don't forget about
the drapes yeah that's rapes i mean yeah
it's crazy but what is frustrating is
she can say things like republicans want
to defund the police she can say things
like no americans are stranded in
afghanistan she can say these verifiably
false things which no press secretary
should be able to say because they're
just simply not truthful and then you
compare that and they just let her get
away with it very few fact checks
compare that to like when i said the
science uh should not get in the way of
opening schools because the science is
on our side jim acosta can take the
first half
the science should not get in the way uh
make it go viral on twitter msnbc it
will be on every chiron when it's the
direct opposite of what i was saying but
they just removed the context in that
case even jim tapper spoke out on my
behalf but my point is in one you can
tell abject falsehoods and the other you
could do your best to report as
truthfully as you can the accounts of
what's going on in the white house but
you'll still be taken out of context
because you've got that r behind your
name for a republican right so i don't
want to make this personally about her
but what what do you make of someone
that could do that job like it's just so
obvious to me she knows she's lying
every bit of it like
do you think that that's just one way to
do the job
oh yeah i think if you're a democrat
it's a very low bar so jen saki can go
out there i think and she can say the
sky is red the grass is blue
and uh the street i just drove down
today was purple and the press will just
not blink an eye you know they sing
happy birthday to one another so i have
to tell you a whole lot i think there
were baked goods transacted i believe i
could be mistaken during one briefing so
um i think she gave them cookies or
something but my point is that's the
kind of cozy coddling relationship which
you know i had diplomatic relationships
with like some members of the press like
who are great like steve holland is a
great example but by and large i don't
think jim acosta would be singing me
happy birthday or caitlyn collins or
anyone
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell